um so al your new book i love the title
like anybody that knows me that sees
your book
abides your book reads book is going to
laugh because literally the thing
said most to me in my life and my career
is your title of your book you look so
much better in person
so i i honestly thought it was just
me like every time i run into people
they're like you look so much better in
person like thank you since 85
of my life is on camera
and they say that to you all the time
every year every day
yeah i go out shake hands you know at
the plaza obviously
and invariably one person at least one
person will say oh my gosh
you look so much better in person
and i know they mean it as a compliment
absolutely you don't want to embarrass
them
but you know like to your point
i make my living on tv that's what i say
so you know yeah did i look better here
just means that i'm scaring small
children on television
yeah like what does that mean do i look
and they're always like you look you're
shorter and you're smaller you're more
petite and i'm just like
do i look like an amazon i was like wait
what
and like or they say that at concerts
they'll come backstage at after concert
and be like oh my god you sound
better in person i'm like great because
most of it's not in person
so solid um it's so it's amazing
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel
please don't make me keep going